let me show you the way that i did this
now
i have a new diagram here okay and
unlike the previous diagrams that i
just showed you which were for a
specific z1 and a specific z2
here i've got z1 and z2 positioned in
somewhat arbitrary positions you can see
i've marked in angles of alpha and beta
because just like
the very first time i tried this
question alpha and beta really can be
equal to
anything you will notice that i've
positioned z1 and z2
in the first quadrant and that's just
for convenience at the end of this proof
i'm just going to
run you through the fact that the logic
i've employed for this proof
does work wherever a and b are they can
be in any quadrants you like and they
can indeed have any magnitude that you
like
but how can i go about this right well
what i want to try and do is if i've got
z1 and z2 here
i want to try and understand what is
happening with this
z1 plus z2 thing that's what i did
up here with this um with this with this
construction over here z1 plus z2 if i
can understand where that is
i can get some geometric relationships
happening
so i'm going to employ some of that same
logic idea this is the whole point of me
using a specific example
which will give me logic that applies
generally
i'm going to keep on thinking of these
things in vector terms right
so if i've got a as the position of z1
and b
is the position of z2 then oa
and ob can be thought of as vectors
that get me to z1 and z2 so
what would z1 plus z2 look like
well it would mean that i carry out
these vectors in sequence i would do z1
and then i would
do z2 which would take me somewhere in
this direction
now luckily for me i've got some
technology here which will allow me to
do this precisely in fact i don't need
to do that
i'm going to take this i can aim
properly
that is my z2 it's sort of an equivalent
vector
to z2 it sends me off further into
the first quadrant and this point up
here which i'm going to mark with a new
color
this point up here will be z1 plus
z 2. let's give that a new name let's
call it p
over here right now this is important
because you can see what i've got up
here to get to z1
plus z2 you can see that there
is there are some angles here that are
going to be related to each other if
let's actually change the color of this
i think it might be a little bit clearer
if i change these both to this and if i
also change this
to be a little bit different okay
you can see what i've got here there's
this kind of the makings of
constructions underneath here
that form actually what kind of shape
this is a rhombus now why is a rhombus
you can see it looks like a rhombus but
how
do i know that that is the case the
answer is
because i know that z1 and z2
the property i know about them is that
they share the same modulus so i can say
well
if this is some modulus r then so is
this
right but that means that because i got
this vector in here by duplicating this
ob
vector right so ap as a vector is the
same as
ob in terms of its direction and its
magnitude
that is also its length right so
therefore i can say well that's
r and by extension same kind of logic
that's r
over there now you may well remember
that what you've got here is a rhombus
which has lots of important properties
for example you can see that i've got
congruent triangles on the opposite
sides of this diagonal in fact let me
just uh i'll shade it in i think i could
use this color
let's make it a bit thinner though let's
highlight this triangle up here
a bit off in terms of my accuracy
there we go all right so let's fill this
in so you can see what's going on here
happy times so do you see that this
triangle
up here is congruent to this triangle
over here why is that well it's got
these two sides here
r and r which are equal and then it's
got this common length here in the
middle so
they are um they both share all
corresponding sides are equal so
therefore
this triangle is congruent to this
triangle and what that means is
all the angles are also going to be
congruent or we would normally say
equal and that's hugely important to me
because my proof has to do
with angles so i've got all my pieces in
place now
i'm going to now start to try and unpack
how it is that i prove
the result up the top which remember
where we're going
it is that the argument of z1
z2 in this case is equal to
the argument of z1 plus
z2 squared okay let's try and do this
so what have i got first well i can say
that
since i should rehearse i should
actually write some of that logic
that i actually was saying out loud
before but i didn't have as part of my
proof
since z1 the modulus of z1 rather
is the modulus of z2 i can say that this
shape here
is going to be a rhombus because of what
i said about all of these signs
being equal so i can say what what's the
name of this shape
o a p b is a rhombus
okay so that's good i now want to use
that fact to try and make some
you know do some work with the angles
inside of this okay
so what is for example let's mark it in
in blue
what is this angle here this is the
angle in the corner
of the rhombus this angle here
angle aob that's the name of it
how do i get it in terms of the names of
the angles that i've already marked
in well you can see i've got alpha
that's this big argument here
and then i've also got beta this little
argument here and uh
the angle aob is just the difference
between those so i guess i would say it
is
alpha the big angle take away beta the
little angle
okay that's really good now i can then
say well if i look at the bottom part
of this angle which i'm going to
highlight
here now that's 2 coarse let's try a
small one this angle in here
this angle is going to be half of that
angle aob
right angle p o b
p o b is going to be exactly half of
that angle how can i reason that
well number one i talked about these
congruent triangles here all angles are
the same
or you could lead to the fact that
because i've already proved that this is
a rhombus
maybe your knowledge of quadrilateral
properties from years seven and eight is
a little bit dusty in there
i can say it's because um diagonals in a
rhombus
diagonals
in rhombus oops that's very messy
o a p
b what do they do they bisect the angles
that they pass through
so that's why i went from alpha minus
beta to half
alpha minus beta okay so what have i got
let's just fill that in
this little blue angle in here is half
of
alpha minus beta okay
now what is the use of that well then i
can say
well to try and get towards argument of
z1 plus z2
squared i first need to work out the
argument of z1
plus z2 which which i have here and i
can get that in terms of these angles i
already have
so i can say all right well let's try
and get to let's see daisy
the argument of z1
plus z2 what is that in terms of all of
my geometric terms
well it's going to be uh let's see here
it's going to be
angle uh b
o c plus angle
p o b which i just worked out there you
can see
um that's p o b there so this is going
to give me
and uh maybe i actually should have
written this first so i'll just
move this down a little bit that will
actually give me the entire angle p
o c so you can follow my logic there and
that's because these are adjacent
angles now i worked out
what each of these were one by
definition and one by this
construction up here so i can say what's
boc that's
beta and then i've got a half
alpha minus beta so this is promising i
can actually collect some like terms
here because i've got
i'm going to put the half terms out the
front first half alpha minus
half beta plus beta that's going to be
half alpha
plus half beta just collecting my beta
terms
together and i'm going to factorize out
that half
now i wonder if if it hasn't already if
this is the point at which everything
has clicked for you
this is the argument of z1 plus
z2 so remember where i'm trying to go
right we already worked out from our
first kind of you know
failure of a proof that we're trying to
get to is alpha plus beta
and i have got that angle but exactly
half here so what should i do i should
double
the argument here z1 plus z2
equals just alpha plus beta
but and there's so many different ways
you could say this but a nice convenient
way
to say it is that double this angle here
is clearly going to be that argument
that's what happens when you take a
complex number
and you multiply it by itself this is
kind of a weird
uh offheader way of using demifour's
theorem right
if you were to square a complex number
z1 plus z2
is this complex number up here what do
you do to its argument
well you double it right so that's me
going sort of backwards in logic so i
might just jot that down
that's me going up here by way of
demarvor's theorem so it's also true
in reverse or you might say it's
converse so that's alpha
plus beta but i can then further say
this is actually also what happens
when you have alpha plus beta being the
arguments of z1
plus the argument of z2 that's what
alpha is
and that's what beta is which is
we're almost there i'm going to take
this here and i'm going to duplicate it
what happens when you're adding
arguments or why would you add arguments
and the answer is it's what happens when
you multiply
two complex numbers together you
multiply
the moduli and you add the arguments
which is what i'm doing
going from that line to that line so
this is the result
as required we went about it a bit of a
a circuitous path but i hope you can see
by my geometric logic
this is how i've landed up here at this
result over here
take a breath now right at the start of
this proof the proof that actually
worked as opposed to me looking at
specific examples right
right at the beginning of this proof i
said yes i know i have drawn z1 and z2
so they are in the first quadrant
um just to make things convenient for me
but
i i sort of suggested that the logic
that i've just employed it will work no
matter where z1 and z2 are so long as
they have the same modulus
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
try and illustrate why that is and also
bring us back to
why we had to use this property here
that z1 and z2 have the same module so
let's
have a look at this dynamically
this is a desmosified version um i don't
know if that's a real word just made it
up
this is a desmos version of what we
constructed just now we have a z1
and a z2 you can see here's my z1 in
blue and my z2 in red
and then z1 plus z2 you can see the
construction there
by way of putting together these
vectors right so the the dotted lines
you can see are the equivalent
vectors just moved over so that you can
make z1 plus z2 happen
okay you can also see this green dotted
circle which is how i'm ensuring that z1
and z2
have the same modulus because they're
the same distance from the origin
um so that's why you've got a consistent
radius so you can see here
that you're going to get this rhombus
situation happening and that's the key
right no matter where um you know you
arrange z1 and z2 with varying angles
you know i can move
i can move z1 up this way or down this
way you can see you're still getting a
rhombus right and that's how the logic
works now this is really important let
me just zoom out a little bit
it's really important now that you can
convince yourself that this will still
work if you move out of the first
quadrant
so if i put z2 over
here in the second quadrant let me see
if i've got that right there you go
you can see z2 is now in a funny
different spot but you're still getting
this rhombus happening between the
origin
z1 and z2 and z1 plus z2 so
still got a still got a rhombus all of
the constructions that i did before
they'll have slightly different letters
or
your subtraction might be going in a
slightly different order but you'll
still get the same bisection of angles
happening
between the z1 vector the z2 vector and
they get bisected
by this z1 plus z2 vector and you can
see i can
move it down into the third quadrant if
i like or indeed the fourth
i can have both of the numbers in uh in
different quadrants so let me move
this one over here that's a bit weird
but you can see always got a rhombus
there and that's because of
the fact that if you add two complex
numbers together
you get the parallelogram law you might
recall that from our very first lessons
our very first weeks in complex numbers
you always create a parallelogram
but and this comes to this specific
question you don't always get a rhombus
why are we getting a rhombus and it's
because z1 and z2
have the same modules they're on the
circumference of this circle
this is where i'm going to now show you
let's bring it back to a first quadrant
example
this is where i'm going to show you why
it is important that you've got the same
modulus
for each one i'm going to give you an
exaggerated example here of
if i move z2 such that it doesn't have
the same modulus as z1 so let's for
example
let's move it in closer here okay
now z1 and z2 no longer share the same
modulus and
so you would expect that our result is
not true and
indeed that is what happens right the
reason why is because if you have a look
let's zoom in here right
if you have a look at what's happened to
our shape here i no longer have a
rhombus i've got a parallelogram still
but the geometric property of rhombus
that i was relying on
namely that you've got these congruent
triangles
but not just congruent triangles they
end up with your angles kind of matching
together
bisecting in the corners you can see
here my angle
you know from z1 to the origin over to
z1 plus z2 you can see
that angle is not the same as the angle
from z2
to the origin up to z1 plus z2 right
one of them is much narrower than the
other you're not getting a bisection of
angles happening
anymore so the congruence is actually
flipped upside down if you have a think
about those two triangles
and so this bisection only happens when
z1 and z2 i'll actually bring z1 in a
bit closer
when z1 and z2 share the same modules
that's what makes
the construction work it's what gives me
the ability to use
this property in here that the diagonals
in a rhombus
bisect those angles so this is really
crucial this is kind of the
the engine of my proof i can't do
anything uh down here you know like
um having these half angles and adding
them all together it ends up completely
different
if you just have a parallelogram so
that's why this result
which is about angles relies on this
basis or foundation which is to do with
lengths
so i hope that was illuminating for you
not just the solution but also
kind of the dead ends that i had to
pursue before i arrived at my actual
solution
i hope me going through my um my proof
has convinced you that actually
these these kinds of things that i did
up here were enormously important for my
brain to um
to wrap some scaffolding around this
question um i still employed logic like
oh
i've got to get to an alpha plus beta
right i knew i was going to get there
when i started out this proof and so it
made my destination a lot easier
to work out so good luck with trying out
questions like this remember
if you usually don't arrive at the
solution the first time through
sometimes that
failed attempted solution will be the
bridge or the scaffolding
to get to the real solution